what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and today i will be
discussing the insane finale of the
fight between
devil union asta and the fused form of
lilith and the ma this was a huge
chapter and it marks an important
turning point in the story
but we have to remember that this is
still only the beginning of the final
showdown
inside the spade kingdom so let's get
into it if you enjoy the black clover
content here on the channel just leave a
like and comment
it only takes a second and it's a
completely free way to directly support
this channel and of course if you're new
to anime pro
or maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet make this the
video that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
there have been a ton of rumors lately
about youtube purging subscribers and
unsubscribing people from channels so
please do me a favor and double check
that you are still subscribed to anime
uproar
finally this video will of course
contain black clover manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution
you have been warned we started off as
asta faces down that
massive devil spirit bomb which
continues to loom dangerously
over the entire spade kingdom capital
the focus of this chapter
is the clash between the highest ranking
devil the fusion of lilith
and the ma and the lowest ranking devil
which is
liba before he developed the ability to
use anti-magic
as this fight unfolds we learned that
hosta only has
two minutes left in his devil union form
so he has to act
fast he has to defeat this overpowered
fused devil
as soon as possible the devil's spirit
bomb is still a threat
and time is running out so asta has to
pull out
all the stops including the demon
dweller sword
asta appears to use some form of black
slash to cut
through the devil's spirit bomb but we
have to say that this is clearly some
sort of powered up
devil union version of black slash and
as a result of this attack
asta is able to break through the devil
fire and devil ice magic
as asta approaches the fused devil liba
inside of asta remembers how he was the
weakest of all the devils on the first
level of the underworld
and he remembers how lilith and ama were
the highest ranking devils
on that same level liebus spent so many
years being bullied and abused by these
highest ranking devils
and at that time he was completely
powerless to do anything to stop them
even if he tried his best he never even
stood a chance against
these devils but now thanks to
anti-magic
and thanks to osta liba is able to stand
up to the fusion of lilith and the mob
and fight against them liebe is
extremely grateful to osta for giving
him this opportunity to stop
lilith and ama an opportunity that he
would have thought impossible
before meeting osta so just like asta
had thanked liba in the past for giving
him the ability to fight and become a
magic knight
liba now thanks asta for everything that
asta has done for him
and this moment really showcases the
fact that asta and liba have an
equal partnership they both depend on
each other
and this partnership is not a one-way
street
and honestly i love seeing the
relationship between these two develop
after learning liba's tragic backstory
i'm so glad that he and asta are
becoming bros
and i think that fighting together
during this arc is going to make their
bond
even stronger but back to the fight
itself this entire experience with asta
and anti-magic is extremely strange to
defuse the devil
and he seems confused and lieben knows
exactly why
this is the case lilith and ama have
always lived as the strongest
devils inside the realm and they were
always the undisputed rulers
of the first floor of the underworld
they lived their entire lives believing
that all a life
exists solely for their own
entertainment and so they are used to
always being in complete control
and dominating every situation as such
lilith and emma have never known fear it
is a completely
alien emotion to them but that is
exactly what they are feeling now
as austin liebe turned out to be
extremely dangerous opponents
nevertheless the fused devil is able to
adjust to the situation
pretty quickly he realizes that even
though asta is extremely dangerous he
cannot possibly maintain that
overpowered devil union form forever
there must be a time limit so the fused
devil decides to run away from asta
if the devil can just evade asta for
long enough then asta will run out of
time and his devil union mode will
disappear
at that point asta won't be able to do
anything against the defused devil
and the entire fight will be over and
this strategy does work for a while
the fused devil is clearly faster than
osta
and no matter what asta does he simply
cannot catch up to the devil
in fact the devil quickly begins to get
cocky again and he calls out asta
mockingly
telling him that he's gonna kill him and
all of his friends and then
all of humanity and since osta can't
catch the devil
there is nothing that asta can do to
stop him things don't look good for
austen liba
at this point and this tells us that as
strong as asta's devil union form
is it is not unbeatable if another
highest ranked devil possesses the same
type of speed that this
fused version of lilith and the mob
possesses they can just outrun
osto's devil union timer and defeat him
but
then at an absolutely crucial moment in
the chapter
knocked returns to the main stage with
an epic
play of the game noct uses what's left
of his shadow magic to grab the fused
devil and restrain him
if only for a second but that brief
moment
is just long enough for asta to catch up
and slash the fused
devil in half the insanely overpowered
fused version of lilith enema
is no more austin liba won with an
important assist from knocked and in the
very next
second austin liba are separated once
again
as their devil union mode runs out so
they managed to defeat the fused devil
at exactly the right moment if they had
waited for even a few seconds longer
it would have been too late literally if
knocked hadn't intervened when he did
austen liebe would have run out of time
and they would have lost this fight
there is no doubt
about it the final page gives us an
awesome image of
asta and libas celebrating their victory
together as bros
and that is how this chapter ends
this is definitely a huge w for asta
and for the entire world but we can't
forget that this battle is far from over
the underworld still has six other
floors and each of those floors has
even more powerful devils than the
devils on the top floor
and as of right now austin liba are no
longer
in their devil union form they just ran
out of time
so if a new overpowered highest ranked
devil appears
anytime soon austen liba won't be able
to stop him
don't get me wrong this is an amazing
victory for asta and liba
but the war is far from over it's too
early to celebrate
i have to say that i really liked the
fact that noct had to get involved
and help asta win this fight if asta was
just taking out every single devil on
his own
things would get boring pretty quickly
however this chapter made it clear that
without knocked help
libya and asta would have lost that
fight teamwork has always been
an essential component in black clover
fights
it's not just about raw power strategy
and teamwork have
always played a major role and i'm glad
that this tradition is continuing
even at this stage of the game black
clover has some of the best
team battles in shonen precisely because
tabata pays
so much attention to teamwork and
strategy and to be honest
that is one of my favorite aspects of
this story
okay now let me know what you guys think
did you like
how this battle ended and what do you
think is going to happen
next are austin liba going to be
sidelined for a while until they can
enter their devil union form again
and maybe other characters are going to
do most of the fighting from now on
or do you think that austin and libra
are going to figure out another way to
keep being useful
on the front line also when do you think
that the next floor of the underworld
is going to open and what type of
highest ranked devil do you expect to
see
emerging from that floor is this devil
going to appear
right away or are we going to get some
breathing room first
let me know down below if you enjoyed
the blacklord content
on this channel please take a second and
leave that like
it really helps a lot and if you are new
to the channel or maybe you watch our
videos but you haven't gotten around to
subscribing yet
please do me a favor and subscribe right
now
the only way to make sure that you're
not gonna miss our videos in the future
is to subscribe hit that notification
bell and then select the option that
says
all you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram
at animeopror a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons who make videos
like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma red
haired raven
and avi these guys are absolute mad lads
and disciples of lord twigo
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans
including ingrada pate heffa algertol dr
cortman the toasted chi
bang emperor otaku spidey life chanel
tungsten tarquez baked buddhist
and you know finally thank you to all of
our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz anatoly
kazatsky qriket xp
rothlin de ora very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokamian water joanne
garcia ted no ted iceparky65 jessica
lafond metal mama
corey mcgowan fat boy games deadly saint
and soul ray slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you